i was so fed up with this story i was so
fed up with it because i just thought
it's just so annoying that you're
putting me in this situation but then if
any uh
make believe or not bro if anyone
stare me in my phone
[Music]
yeah man well guys what are you saying
um you can as you can see
new merch gang you must
looking clean and nap i won't get up and
show you the back but you already know
what's on the back summer edition logo
merch pop in if you don't know check the
website links are in the bio links are
in everything you know on instagram or
twitter facebook youtube snapchat we're
there we're everywhere cause you know
the webs you know how everything goes
you know i'm about to do a little sip
sip before the episode starts hope you
guys are having a good day jamie thinks
i'm rapping so he's doing gun fingers
here there and everywhere but you know i
might as well be you feel me cuz cheers
[Laughter]
follow the real like comment subscribe
man i hope you guys are doing well hope
you guys enjoy the two eps a week for
those that aren't on the patreon make
sure you run us rp three pound a day
three point two pounds a day a month can
be a day runners to pee come on the
usual vibes you know
um yeah man just get in the comments get
on the tick tock get in the comments
there as well algorithm is moving crazy
you already know we pop on tick tock
your boys regardless stupid viral stupid
viral on tick tock you're gonna see us
everywhere so you know you gotta you
gotta jump in you gotta feel amongst the
crowd type in the comments you know just
be part of it you know make some friends
make some friends that's it draws a ting
in the comments
i dare one of you to draw the ting's own
comments oh and i'll be gasps draw the
thing in the comments come on
pat on that pattern that for us man
let's
let's start a community let's keep the
community going because we've already
got a community and that's thanks to you
guys so yeah ma hope you guys are doing
bless
um
and yeah happy monday
yeah mom how are you
how are you doing today
me
you brother chilling i'm blessed my
brother i'm live yeah mom i'm feeling
good
i'm happy with myself yeah mom um
jim's been tough for me at the minute
bro i'm not gonna lie to you bro i'm not
trained in a minute but i'll let you go
first i just wanna be
me again i want i want i want i want
what do i want tell me
i want i want um
depth
i hear you i hear you i want death i
hear you and
i want bulk but it looks it just looks
dense bro yeah yeah yeah not too like
yeah yeah
not stuck
but everything just looks thick and it
just looks like there's a there's a
nucleus in there
every muscle has its own nucleus yeah
everybody i want
i want to be mean it's hilarious um but
yeah man i'm struggling to get into a
routine yeah
everything's a bit hectic at home at the
minute but i'm hoping in a few weeks it
should be better
um i just need to be bang on it bro bang
on it
your boy needs to prioritize cardio with
it i'm at that age now do you i need to
start prioritizing cardio my heart it's
not what it was same i've i always try
and avoid it
[ __ ] hate cardio i hate cardio as
well like the only cardio i do is sex
brother i always avoid cardio
cardio but your boy's tummy tum
your boy's got a tummy time now it's
coming my time is coming i'm not gonna
lie to you i need to thomas tell me my
time is coming i need to i need to do
something about it
um but yeah i'm gonna hit the gym i need
to get back into the gym routine very
soon it's been a busy couple weeks
but yeah i think i'm gonna back uh jump
back in tomorrow or i think i've got
some yeah what time tomorrow so yeah
make the week
fruitful and just keep it keep on
keeping on i need to i need to get back
into it man to be fair depending on what
time my train lands
tomorrow i might have time oh okay it's
time to squeeze it okay have you got
your stuff with you or you're gonna go
yard and then nah i've got stuff okay
i've got stuff um yeah i can rock it man
because
i can't keep living like this bro it's
um
it's a crazy time at the moment but
we're busy but i mean we have to make
sacrifices but we're here you know it's
true we're here hope you guys are doing
well anyway i'm gonna get into a few
hours fun fact of the day
so in 1987
ontario man called kenneth parks drove
20 kilometers to the house of his
in-laws he beat his mother-in-law to
death with the tyre iron and strangled
his father-in-law he was subsequently
arrested but found not guilty in a court
after a jury concluded that he must have
been sleepwalking
20 km as you drive there 20 kilometers
i don't care what any jury says yeah if
i'm in the crowd
and i'm friends of the accused or the
abused rather not the accused
send him to penitentiary oh bro there's
no way anyone is driving 20k
sleepwalking it's impossible
to be fair
i've heard stories not sleepwalking per
se but stories of people who take um
what's the thing that helps you sleep
um
what's the this is there's a medication
you can take that helps you sleep it's
called
um
oh [ __ ] me
[ __ ] me
what's it called
james i don't know he's called like uh
does it begin with a
either because we're a or v i feel
i
i don't know i'm not gonna lie anyway
is it advil
is that a cpm1
yes yes because people pop advils want
to go on a plane okay cool yeah i think
it's advil yeah yeah
i've heard people
who take that and um
bro they have crazy [ __ ] happen in the
night so uh i was listening to joe rogan
he's got a couple stories of where
you know
kevin james the actor
kevin james uh
he played
james let me google it he's um
paul black he's the the main guy in
hitch the white guy in hitch fat guy
okay okay the guy that played the mall
cop yeah more cop paul black more yeah
yeah yeah yeah my man oh yeah just
googled him yeah i didn't know that was
his name yeah so he he's got a story
where he said that he he took it after
went to bed
woke up the next day went into the
kitchen
and
he'd cooked in like an entire steak
dinner
in his sleep
nah brother all the trimmings no brother
any sleep in his sleep because the thing
is i've seen videos of i can't remember
what show it was like it was an actual i
was on actual tv and i've seen videos of
people sleepwalking doing random [ __ ]
but doing [ __ ] that looks like they're
awake
and it's like
how
is this possible
yeah like how is this possible it
doesn't make sense it's not i don't know
what it is but it's something satin in
the brain where you're just not you i
don't even know you're conscious you're
not there you're not conscious yeah
because it makes sense there's the ones
where they've said they've taken advil
they've gone sharp done all sorts brav
and they're just there like that
well the eyes are open nah
their eyes are open they're awake fam to
be fair how else is his man driving 20km
exactly true they're awake bro they're
awake fully awake but their brain is off
no i'm um they're not talking to people
they're doing stuff that their brain is
not there i refuse to believe it i
refuse to believe i refuse to believe
man's got the cognitive
what's the word i'm looking for the
cognitive ability
to let
to let alone drive 20k
with his eyes open but not consciously
awake
to like stop at traffic lights not hit
anyone's all of these factors it takes
to drive as you're awake to then go to
the yard get into the yard grab a tire
iron kill the mum strangle the like do
all of these things to then drive back
home or whatever bro bro it doesn't i
know what you mean i don't believe that
in this case i don't i think that's full
of [ __ ] i'm just saying there are some
cases i know especially with the driving
they're driving bro have you never have
it where you just like switch off when
you're driving yeah and you rock up to
the place and you like jump because
you're like how the [ __ ] did i even just
forget you were driving yeah yeah yeah i
don't remember one bit of that journey
i've been there i was in a different
space i've been there brother that
scares me when that happens
completely automated
not present at all
um
yeah so i can see kind of like that the
mechanics behind that but murdering two
people come on big man coincidentally
your in-laws that you're murdering yeah
yeah how strange is my team
yeah
there's a backstory behind that like you
obviously hear your in-laws they've
obviously
wronged you in some form or some manner
so you have to
you have to do a couple years i took
them out man didn't even want to allow
the wife he said these might need to go
you have to do a couple years behind
bars you have to it doesn't make sense
things like that i don't make sense and
to be fair 1987 i feel like if something
like that happened now
then again i don't know anything or i
don't know much about the court of law
and like the in in terms of how jury or
jury duty has changed
but i just assumed like if that happened
today man's going pen i don't care what
anyone says yes it happened in 1987. but
if happened today yeah you go in jail
bro you have to go you can't finesse a
jury these days you can't they know
everything you can't finesse a jury
these days you are going to jail so yeah
kenneth you're a lucky brother but it's
also you need to you need to get checked
because amanda in the comments guys have
you ever do you know anyone that's ever
slept slept what sleep walked or do you
sleepwalk yourself because i i find that
very
i find that very fascinating but also
very scary because i feel like you're in
a i feel like that's a different
dimension you're in a different world
completely but you're you're
you're conscious but you're not
conscious at the same time things like
that don't make sense to me i've um
i don't know if i've told you this i've
uh i've i
it's very intermittent okay it's not
constant but when it does happen it
happens in like clusters okay but i like
try and sleep [ __ ]
oh explain so
i've i've had moments where like
basically
if i'm in bed um
with like
well like my girl or my go at the time
or whatever
um
where i will be like ridiculously
horny okay but i am asleep okay and it's
only i've noticed it happened a few
times but basically where i'll be crazy
honey and i'll try and smash
now if they're on it
and we actually do smash i'll wake up
okay and there's been times where i've
woken up
where i've been like oh but i it's weird
it's a wake up but i know what i'm doing
do you know what i mean i know how i got
to this position when i've woken up i
know how i'm here
it's not like i'm like wow what am i
doing on top of you it's like and i
remember from there what am i doing on
top of you
is that climbed over bro i remember from
there yeah yeah yeah and sometimes it's
but sometimes it's such a flashback to
reality that i'm not even horny anymore
okay and i'm like oh wow like i don't
think i can like i'm just a bit
wavy like i don't know what's going on
but there's other times where if they're
not on it
big man
they'll tell me the next day that i was
trying to sing last night and i was like
no i wasn't big man i was sleeping
they're like
yes you were really yeah 100
and it's happened to you like a couple
times or like bear time really
bad times more than ten
okay
um
do you feel like what has happened the
night before were you drunk before
nothing
and there's no correlating factors as
far as i can tell
that attribute to it
it hardly it doesn't ever hardly ever
happens but when it does happen it
happen it can happen like three four
five nights in a row
but then it won't happen again for like
a year what the [ __ ] it's weird bro
it's weird
my libido's up up up sometimes i hear
that though i hear that because but i i
don't i don't know because there are
times i wake up
or like
i'm in that you know when you're just in
that realm of
you're about to wake up but you're still
tired your eyes are still closed but
you're horny but that kind of morning
sex vibe but you're not awake awake
and you just feel like i just i just
need to [ __ ] right now i need to [ __ ]
something right now obviously you've got
your mrs or whoever that's with you in
your bed at the time
but
as soon as i start trying to pat in a
way to [ __ ] i'm conscious i'm awake you
know it's not like it's a subconscious
thing yeah so i've never been in that
situation but i can kind of understand
it maybe maybe
but yeah that's um that's different bro
that's different for me horrible not a
fan of it i can imagine um
[Music]
but yeah i i i'm not i'm not sure the
the mechanics of the sleepwalker
oh sleepwalking this is that's a scary
thing
i couldn't
wake up i'm probably like what go piss
or go get some drink of water or
something and see like my missiles or
something just bowling through the yard
just sleepwalking brother bros mad
i would panic
i would panic if i saw i don't know why
because well i do know why it's because
i've never seen that happen to me before
obviously i know people sleepwalk
obviously i know it's a thing
but i've never known anyone to be mad at
people oh my goodness i wouldn't know
what to do
yeah i think i've done i've had like a
half sleep walk in my life before uh
where i was drunk it was when i was a
teenager okay and i basically
i might have told you this before i
basically pissed on my chest of drawers
i don't know if you've told me that
maybe you have i don't remember
basically i was drunk but i was just
when i was young so i was like 16. i was
still in sixth form okay and i went out
um the night before got drunk came back
home
and i remember in the night
waking up going to the toilet
to piss and then come back to bed and
going back to sleep
the next day i wake up
get out of bed go to my chest of jaws
and like the carpet is soaking wet fam
so basically you dreamt that you went to
the top i dreamt i went to the toilet
but i actually got up and just pissed on
the floor
but i vividly remember the toilet bro
family when i was younger right
i used to piss the bed for bats when i
was a youth when i was a you you i used
to piss the dead brother it's
embarrassing it was more embarrassing
from my parents than it was i used to
pissed a bit but my dreams were so vivid
that big i am i'm confident i went to
the toilet you know
because because you know the you know
the layout you know the blueprint of
your yard yeah when you're dreaming yeah
it seemed so
real bro and i'm like yeah yeah yeah the
funny thing is it's one of them ones
where
in the dream you're pissing your person
in this um you're pissing in the toilet
right but
i think there's there is a moment where
i think when maybe when i'm
about to finish pissing i realize it's a
dream but i can't do anything about it
and i also don't wake up oh okay so i'm
trapped in this abyss
and then i wake up like seven hours
later when it's morning time yeah yeah
yeah my bed is soaked and i'm vexed
i'm just vexed i used to uh bro there
are so many times i used to dream that i
was pissing and i'll just i'll just murk
the bed i would just murder the bed when
i was a you yeah man i would destroy the
bed it was so annoying
it was
so annoying my brother used to piss the
bed
when we were little kids yeah we used to
piss the bed and when we stayed with my
dad on weekends for a couple years where
he lived we would share a double bed and
his so we'd have asked he would stay in
the spare room and it'd be a double bed
and there was a double bed in there
would share it brav every single time i
brought a pistol bed
i feel bad now because i would wake up
going mad at him bro
mad at him because obviously i'll just
be asleep and i might listen that way
and soaking wet cold now on my leg yeah
i'll jump out of bed oh my god yeah and
i'll just scream at him
screaming and this was not my fault it's
not my fault i'm a [ __ ] sake bro
stop pissing a [ __ ] bed i don't want
to be here with your [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] pissy sheets bro i don't want to
be here yeah and then yeah when we were
kids yeah i bet he must have felt
mortified oh i can imagine mortified i
can imagine brother i hated it i [ __ ]
hated it if i had come on i hate it was
so [ __ ] but yeah man it's a weird thing
man it is it is in the bed it's um i
don't know
i'm sure a lot of people even like till
now not even till now but like there are
moments where
you know when you slip in and out of
consciousness and subconsciousness and
there are many times at night i feel
like i need to piss but my dream relates
to my reality
and
i feel like i've gone to the toilet i'm
about to go to the toilet and i clocked
myself that big man this is a dream you
know so you kind of you kind of pause
the thing you kind of shake yourself and
wake up yeah but there are also many
times where
for example i'm i'm sleeping i know i'm
sleeping but my conscience is awake so
for example if i can i can hear stuff
that's happening in the real world but
i'm asleep but if i hear like a bang
that bang will resonate in my dream
and it's like how does the brain work i
don't know how the brain catches that
but i've had so many times before
where i'm dreaming and then someone's
knocking on my door
and then knocking knocking knocking and
in my dreams someone's not the one
and you're in the thing is like it's not
like the knock doesn't coincide with the
dream it's like i'm already dreaming i'm
i'm about somewhere and there's a
daughter i was coincidentally walking
towards the door
that's getting knocked yeah i don't know
how the dream patterns it makes no sense
bro it's like an inception the brain
just
handles it it gets handles it i'm sure
that happens to everyone because yeah
handles it bro
oh wow it's horrible
oh my goodness oh my goodness um but
i've got a um i've got what would you do
scenario now
um
let me see which one i'm gonna do
i'll do this one all right after
receiving a wildly inappropriate face
massager from my aunt it quickly became
my first sex toy i don't know how that
bad so my boyfriend's [ __ ] me with
the mis with this massager that's
definitely a small cheap vibrator
my mom comes home and we've got to
pretend like nothing's going on
she comes in to talk to us and starts
talking about the face massager while
picking it up and rubbing it all over
her face
then goes and rubs it on my face too
and then on my boyfriend's face
i almost had a heart attack thinking
she'd be able to tell it's literally
just been inside of me
luckily she didn't and still doesn't
know that she's nuzzled my dildo
nozzles
all right you're the boyfriend in this
situation right yeah yeah yeah you've
you've patted a thingy with your girl
dog yo you're [ __ ] about with this
face massager slash dildo play with it
play with the player her mum runs round
back the yard she grabs it and starts
talking about but she starts putting it
all over her face then she puts it on
your girl's face i hear her daughter
then she's about to put her in your face
what do you do i'm smacking out
[Music]
[ __ ] i'm smacking out other hand how
are you explaining the situation
um
bro
i do not know
i do not know i don't know bro but my
initial i just know my body will react
and i will smack it out of my hand
and i'll i don't know i'll say something
like why are you trying to rub
everyone's face on everyone's face
i don't want everyone's grease on my
grease bro you're a quick thinker dude
yeah yeah get all this away from me man
stop rubbing this is your face massage
and try and rub it on my face that's
disgusting
um but yeah that's
that girl's a freak as well
man said cut to next scene my
boyfriend's [ __ ] me with my mom's
face massager
jesus she just saw that and said that
looks fun that looks like it can work
bang me with that
that's sexy not even like oh that look
that doesn't that remind you of a such
and such and then maybe let's go to a
shop and get a such and such that's i
want that i want that inside me i want
oh no i mean now
let's thank me with that
that's raunch she's a freaky freak
that's raunch yeah
that'll tell me
a hundred percent tell me she said
100 she'll come to me just like james
fit it i wouldn't smile i wouldn't
frown straight face smack out of my hand
she will be
what are you doing james i don't know i
don't know you'd panic after that after
she reacts you i bet you paddy bro i
would
the girl's just your girl just staring
at you fam i'll stare straight back at
her what would you expect this is your
fault
this is your fault but then again i
might just firm it
my girl's palm juice on my face isn't
this minor really
is actually minor it's the mum that's
going through it imagine
all right random scenario this thing has
happened right this thing is patterned
out but the mum knows what it is the mum
knows it's a dildo-esque type
product right so she's put it on her
face whatever trying to like break the
ice whatever put on her daughter's face
but
when she no she puts on your face you
firm it let's say you firm it this time
she puts on your face you firm it she
puts on her daughters whatever but then
she puts it on her face
stares at you
[ __ ] she's a milf
she [ __ ] stares at you but she she
does it in a way that you know that you
know that she knows that we know she's
making innuendo things
she's doing she's doing all
sorts brother
all sorts brother and she's yo let's say
you're like 18 19 20 and she's a good
like
40
but she's banging brother
if you thought the daughter was nice
you can see where she got it from
daughter slips to the toilet now or
she's like oh mom you're embarrassing me
mum you're embarrassing me and she's
like ah i'm just going to go to the to
the shop real quick or whatever you
decide to stay you don't go
and the mom's done all the tingle around
she's like ah james
that was funny that thing upstairs is
funny right
i'm like
and she looks at you oh i know what that
is i don't know i know that's a i know
that's a sex toy
how about we use it
how about we use it
and you've seen you've seen her mom you
know that yeah yeah she looks she looks
tired why are you looking at your nails
brother what do you want me to say here
she looks tight she looks ripe and tight
she's a nice petite figure but curvy
curvy she's like oh where'd she go she's
going to the shell down the road she's
going to be at least 20 minutes
i'll say first of all big man before we
take this only fair far
so you're telling me you knew what it
was and you still rubbed it on my face
you knew what you were doing and then
you rubbed it on my face that's
disrespectful to begin with she's like
i'm a freak b
i'm a free i don't care
i'm a [ __ ] freak oh she
can say that she swears
to say that to me no one can say that
she swears like
i was so fed up with your story i was so
fed up with it because i just thought
it's just so annoying that you're
putting me in this situation but then if
any uh
make believe or not bro if anyone
stared me in my boat said i'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] freak
your heart will leave your chest 100
a hundred percent what
what what did you say 20 minutes get
your gums off
bro
that's 15 minutes of chill time
afterwards
get your [ __ ] gums off now
now you never look me in my boat
both eyes open and say i'm a [ __ ]
freak oh i'd shudder
james
bro i would i didn't even know i don't
know what i'd do
i'd probably
i'll probably panic i would definitely
panic because
it's like um
when we used to do obviously we spoke
about this on podcast before we used to
do um butler in the buff blah blah blah
back in the day and we were what between
like 19 21 i can't remember so obviously
in this scenario around that age
and older women at that time
like 10 that 10 11 years ago
we
we didn't know how to pattern that
i didn't even know what to say or do i
just didn't know how to pattern that but
if you gave me
an older woman
if i was 18 now with my mentality now
i know if i was doing butters in a buff
in my mentality at 1920
wow would have been slept a lot sooner
fam i was just about to say i would have
been fired a long time ago
a long long long time ago brother
because no one can tell me i'm a [ __ ]
freak and i don't care who knows it
that's your daughter's boyfriend big man
nah she's a single mom no she's a single
mom
i have to think how much do i want this
relationship oh i don't want this
relationship at all yeah i don't want
this result i take for free i'm doing it
i don't know how i'm doing it don't get
me wrong i don't know how i'm doing it
but that's had the mother and daughter's
problem now oh yeah
i will have to yeah to be fair i will
i'll gulp
go on my phone block my girlfriend's
number
bang the mum
and then just leave and no one's seen me
again but she'd be like she knows where
you live what do you do and she's gonna
do what
and she's gonna she's gonna do what
[Laughter]
bro
oh nah that is [ __ ] hilarious so
asking what were you doing what were you
thinking i don't know what do you think
what do you expect from me ask your mum
bro sure he wants a thug
sure he wants a thug if she found one
get off my doorstep because it doesn't
end well for me or you
because i know we're done i know fam and
i don't want you to want me back
oh because i know what i did oh family
and then tutus now right all right you
and obviously you and this girl you
break up whatever because you have to
it's inevitable right
and maybe like a year down the line
um
she goes to obviously you're of age but
your girl goes all your ex at a time
goes to uni somewhere else to another
city and let's say coincidentally you go
to uni in your sea
and then somehow somehow she just
patents it she passes your eye to your
sight in the mum but mom does the mom
powers your eyes she's hitting me up
again hit me up she's like
my daughter's away roll through when you
want oh i'm banging out every other
wednesday oh brother
brother i'm a uni student brother and
there's a 40 year old that just wants
just pipe constantly
i'll bang on constantly bruh constantly
i'm exhausted
you'll be drained yeah 100 there'll
become a timer like not anymore yeah of
course
the thing is i wouldn't know when that
would be i i don't think for me i don't
think it'd be very long
because the the novelty of it yeah it's
just like um it's just like how many
times do you have to bang a stripper
before you're not buying a stripper
anymore you're just banging a woman now
yeah jesus christ sorry yeah you're just
not banging that you know what i mean
yeah like once you've after you've
banged a stripper like more than what
three four times yeah it meant i'm not
banging the sugar anymore i'm banging
sophie yeah
tell me yeah the novelties and the whole
lore of it is just yeah it's not sexy
yeah yeah that's how i'd feel about
banging like my my girlfriend's mom or
my ex-girlfriend's mom or whatever
pause do you think you're thinking that
because you're a 30-year-old man or do
you think you would be different as an
80-year-old boy i think i'd actually be
worse as an 18 year old boy
i think as a 30 year old man i can at
least appreciate her as like
like a sexy older woman and like in a
longer term
as an 18 year old boy it would be all
novelty for me mm-hmm all novelty-based
but that's my point though because
because i'm saying
sorry
obviously you're gonna be an 18 year old
boy so i feel like you're saying the
number two aware of quick because you're
thinking as a 30 year old man that's my
that's what i'm saying so if you're
thinking as an 18 year old boy
in that situation do you still think
like the novelty wear off soon or would
you still be gassed in a moment or
[ __ ] uh
i think the novelty would wear out still
soon because my novelty would be wearing
out based on what's happening in in and
around
this banging situation okay because at
some point or another she's going to
tell me about
[ __ ] karen at work yeah
she's not just going to be sexy
she's going to want to have some form of
conversation yeah okay and then we're
going to realize that we're two
generations apart yeah and i'm gonna be
like yuck i'm done
she's probably gonna be like yeah yeah
exactly yeah yeah exactly
what am i gonna talk to her about yeah
i'm 18 bro what have i got to say what
are you bringing to the table yeah bro
both of us would be like yeah this is
worn off
like it has to just be skin family it
can't be anything else because as soon
as you have a conversation you'll be
like oh
now i feel like i'm banging an 18 year
old boy and now i feel like i'm banging
a four-year-old woman i hear you [ __ ]
yeah man she's talking about her hot
flushes and [ __ ]
i'm like no
no i'm done this is just not for me i'm
literally done fair enough fair enough
fair enough enough but it'd be cool at
the moment
um and yeah if you're 18
that relationship can get dusted i don't
care
i do not care i'll block her number
before i've even gone upstairs
ah that's hilarious that is hilarious
i'd have to bro
i'd have to and i
i think i just have to be brutal to her
as well to the moment to the daughter
okay and to be like babies i'm sorry i
actually am sorry sorry it doesn't you
don't deserve this yeah but it's just
one of them things you're never going to
get this opportunity again yeah i don't
know whether you're going to ask any guy
that's my age he's going to say he'll do
the same thing especially if the mum's
at milf yeah is your mum banging bro and
she was down i'm sorry and obviously now
like i don't even know what to say like
yo your relationship's probably [ __ ]
with your mom
and like hey man this definitely [ __ ]
with me but best of luck in it i hope
you heal from this whatever i can do to
help but
i did it
if i could go back in time i'd probably
do it again damn lads fellas in the
comments let me know what you do would
you guys you know what they do
you can ask but yeah we all know what
they do let me know
you guys would do would you leave your
girl you're 18 19 20 would you leave
your girl to [ __ ] your girl's mum
and your the mum's a milf
the mom's a [ __ ] milf what would you
do and how would you have the situation
that was not
jesus
of course you know what they're doing
bro your silly questions sometimes
you're rhetorical silly questions
not everyone's like husby there are no
18 year old boys i know but i know i
know because i know what i was like
what boy is going to comment and say now
i'd rather stick it out
you never know
nah
they're all doing it ladies what would
you do if you're the girlfriend or the
mum what would you do
that's what i want to know as well
what do you mean if there's a girlfriend
what do you want them to say i don't
know brother i'm trying to figure out
from a woman's perspective what would
they do if what
if they were in that if their
boyfriend's done it or not
or about to do or that the situation is
about to happen but what i want to know
bruv i don't know how how that would
affect their relationship with their mom
brother because there were a woman
saying some of them has probably
happened
not necessarily a boyfriend i guarantee
there's women i've i've i've met a girl
whose mom was freak
i've met a girl
who was younger than me have you told me
maybe not i don't think i have okay i've
met a girl who's younger than me
and her mom was banging her friends of
her age
no way
so when i was 20
she must have been like 18
okay and her mum was banging her like 18
17 18 year old mom at the time
big woman bro
she's old enough to have an 18 year old
daughter yeah she was like 40.
[ __ ] the commanding would have been gas
of course they were had had you ever
seen the mum yeah i've seen them she
ain't paying she knows she wasn't paying
but that's what they're saying
the novelty of it bro
18 year old boy mom's trying to bang wow
of course they did it
and they were friends with the the girl
they didn't care the daughter didn't
care no the door occurred the guys
didn't care of course the guys didn't
care
of course the guys didn't care
especially if it's not a relationship
thing with a daughter of course yeah
they didn't care bro they ran through
the mum
they
not on not at the same time but there
was multiple
wow yeah she's a freak
she's a [ __ ] freak yes i would have
been in the queue oh so would have i at
that time when i heard about officers i
would have done the same thing and your
mom's not even nice
a hundred percent would have done the
same thing too much for me 100 bro 1
million that's why i get vex when like
you hear about these stories of like
these 15 year old boys who like get
seduced by their tv teachers and stuff
and the teacher gets sacked and the boys
they're like oh the boys are traumatized
he's not traumatized he was hard as [ __ ]
oh bro the boys were down they've never
felt so lucky they've never felt skin
like that before they've never sucked
teeth since they were you bro they've
never been in that situation they'll
kill for it again they would they could
not believe how lucky that they were
[ __ ] i'm vex i didn't have any sociopath
teachers like that i'm so living none of
my teachers have been paying to my
knowledge
none of my teachers have been like
oh my god why i would give to [ __ ] you
peng i don't know i can't think of
anyone
that springs to mind we had one supply
pe teacher
she was banging she was banging
i didn't even had anyone like
blatantly flirted with or tried
obviously oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah my boy adam did
he took it too far bro okay to the point
where it got like oh give me the story
let me see if this hit me the stories um
so yeah
i think she was like she was like
eastern european
she was like petite i already know she's
a friend she was early early 20s
probably she was young for a teacher and
we must have been 14
year 9 yeah yeah yeah yeah probably year
nine late it's year 10 but i'm not gonna
say year nine
and um she was bad but she she's not
banging now if we look at her now i know
what you mean but in school as an in a
authority figure she was banging of
course and then um
yeah flipping
she was there i think she was taking us
into the tennis courts we're gonna do a
tennis lesson and then all the boys are
just like oh she's painting oh she's
paying it
and then you know but stupid school boys
have stupid conversations yeah like oh
do you think she'll be on it do you
think do you think you could pattern it
do you think
that obviously no one can [ __ ] panic
back patting it like everyone shut up
but at that time you guessed each other
up ah bro i could move i'll move to
almost her no no no no you can never
move towards that to my boy adam was
like i'll move to rags and then you said
like oh miss you're paying you know and
then she was like oh cool
and then he just
said it again nah i feel like you're
paying
and then
uh she was like okay like can we move on
from this subject like i'm trying to
take this lesson yeah and he was like
yeah cool cool and then i can't remember
i can't remember i think he actually
squeezed the body no he never i think he
did never i think it was this year nine
no we
never 85
certainly squeezed away
because it escalated who had that's all
i remember he escalated he got draped
out the lesson by one of the male
teachers oh yeah he was probably the
male teacher was probably shadow [ __ ]
as well probably but um yeah because he
he took it i i'm pretty sure that's what
it was because it was went from mild
little like flirting kind of thing to
being told to stop
to the point where escalated fam and she
was like nah
got one of the guy teachers one of the
girl teachers grips him up and took him
out no and i remember feeling so
uncomfortable
when he told him that
for the whole situation yeah yeah where
he took it that extra level where i was
psyched
yeah oh what are you doing bro what are
you doing bro were you doing one of the
games yeah it's all funny games now you
just sexually assaulted someone
you're 14 cars it doesn't end well here
oh yeah bro it's tough damn it was tired
it was the author of aftermath was he
like he wasn't even that bad i don't
think he got in trouble obviously but he
wasn't like he didn't get like kicked
out of school or anything and he still
she still taught him as a tattoo lesson
not that he was not in general she was
literally there
she
she
was
weak
full-time teacher she was there for like
a week
she was there for like a week um so that
was her there was another teacher
she wasn't really paying but she was
like mid-20s
[ __ ]
perhaps
it was ridiculous it didn't even make
sense
and then nothing ever like that but like
um with her but i remember thinking
sexy
and she married one of the other male
teachers okay and all i remember when i
heard that they were getting married
they were engaged in stuff all i
remember thinkers oh he's loving life
bro
with them tigs he is loving life
i was livid by a
living about it like say you could do
anything about that i was next up yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i remember thinking
no
he's banging her and i've never banged
anyone anywhere near yeah i was never i
was like yeah eight year nine but i
remember thinking [ __ ] i'm so jealous
i'm so jealous
he's banging her oh i've been teenage
boys long oh yeah man it's the hardest
thing in the world being a teenage
teenage boy man we're just horny
oh it's long anything turns us on the
[ __ ] wind blows in the right way
big man oh it's it's mad
it's mad so yeah yeah
it's tough out there man
oh god it's tough
but um
what you got for me yeah i went to
i went to
uh
i went to cinema the other day to watch
black widow
i've seen it you seen it yeah i saw it
good i saw it on disney plus what did
you think i thought i thought the action
was really good i thought the like
storyline itself was really good as well
i feel like because obviously it's in
the past
um it ties in very well and it also
leads into a like a black widow too
because of the ending as well so i felt
like it was a it was a good premise
there's definitely not a black widow too
but like it gave the illusion yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but um
i don't know what i felt about it to be
fair i like angel i thoroughly enjoyed
the action digital fighting scenes i
enjoyed it the five
the the fighting scenes were on quad to
be fair
um
but i don't know how i felt about it i
really do not know how i felt about it
i felt like it was all right
but um
there was a few things that annoyed me
about it like the dad role the my man
[Music]
like he's the only yeah that's what
annoyed me for one he's the only brayer
in that entire movie with superpowers
and he does nothing okay he does nothing
for the whole thing he does one little
jump thing
and he flipped one lorry or whatever
when he was there apart from that he got
him scraps as well bear scraps did
nothing just got topped up
he did nothing for the whole film which
i was a bit like this is annoying
um
why her sister has a russian accent i do
not know
um
i'm trying to think do i know why
they weren't even based in russia were
there she was born in flipping america
yeah she grew up in america
and then
maybe they did some sort of
like the red room training yeah red room
thing because i think that was the main
guy right was him the main guy meant to
be russian like the main antagonist yeah
so the main the main thing with the red
room is is in russia so maybe yeah but
they're all supposed to be because scala
did the red room too yeah yeah i know
they both did it
um and the point in the red room is
they're supposed to be like
inconspicuous spies
everywhere yeah
so it just made no sense for her to have
a russian accent since like she's not
supposed to be
you're not supposed to be able to like
place her where she's from or anything
like that it just didn't make sense to
me when she got russian accents i don't
know it just didn't make any [ __ ]
sense to me don't the first thing that
comes to mind is the reason why she's
still got a russian accent
or the reason why skyler on the other
hand hasn't got a russian accent is
because scarlett has spent a lot more
time
in america because she's been an avenger
for so long
i mean yeah that's the only thing
actually never had a russia she's never
had a russian but she can put a russian
accent on because i've i'm sure she's
done
russian accent scenes in yeah for sure
that's the point so yeah she's she
they're supposed to be able to mimic any
accent yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that's what i'm saying like they can all
do accents and they can all
if to be like a widow you should be able
to do everything yeah you should be here
but if someone tells you you're a
nigerian fan you should be able to pass
off as a nigerian yeah yeah that's the
point so i was like right but if you
were born and raised for the most part
in america
and then you learn to speak russian
surely if you could choose any accent
you'd just choose the one that you were
born with
i don't know but
okay
logistically speaking i understand that
because yeah scarlett you're right
scarlett can do russian accents you can
do like she's supposed to be able to
speak like a gajillion languages um
which they all are supposed to be so i
didn't understand like that just doesn't
make sense
that's a [ __ ] massive spider that was
it last time wasn't it yeah it's been
there for me i've been watching it
every time i like look out when i'm
talking just trying like artists
oh i know there's eggs in there that's
disgusting bro
it's been a time that's disgusting
um
right i've got a little um this is
you're going to be annoyed with this one
what so you know when i said we've got
fan fan suggested one's got a ghost yes
um someone sent this one in
and i just thought i'm just gonna ask
you just to make you feel uncomfortable
one's gotta go
your mom your dad or your sister jesus i
know
jesus
um oh my god um
[Music]
it's peak because i'm only basing it off
the current
forms of relationship i have with them
right now
and
if it's based on that it would have to
be my dad
because
i talk to him a lot less than i talk to
my mom and my sister
like i said everyone knows i've said
this on here before my mom just checks
on me like sporadically yeah yeah she
messages me i message back she doesn't
mess with me again for the next day or
so you know so she just tried just to
know where i'm alive
whereas i talked to my pops very
sporadically and i talk to my sister a
lot more because obviously she's got a
kid now and obviously i'm trying to get
more involved with my nephew so i think
because of that
it would have to be my dad but
i'm also trying to
it's weird because i'm also trying to
not necessarily mend my relationship
with my pop spot make it but make it
stronger because i've got a good
relation i've got a great relationship
with my mom i've got a decent
relationship with my sister but me and
my pops don't talk that much because
obviously i live up here now blah blah
he's got his own life i've got my own
life and we're adults now you know we're
not kids anymore you know i'm
technically his son but i don't think he
sees me as a son anymore he sees me as a
man yeah so it's hard to
break that barrier and especially
because we have not been
that close whilst i was growing up
anyway he's just been my dad as opposed
to being like my father figured yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so it's tough so i'd probably have to
say my dad purely because of that aspect
or probably because of that scenario but
what about yourself would you say one's
gotta go um your mom your dad or your
brother
my mom and dad are my brother
that's actually a tough one
i was trying to think about why you was
answering yours because i knew you were
going to ask me back
um it's actually very it's it's actually
very difficult bro of course it is um i
mean i would love to just say oh no i
wouldn't love to say my dad but in this
in the same respect
like obviously
i i'm not as close with my dad as i am
with my mum and my brother but my dad
also has another family
so then if i was to lop off my dad that
mana just makes sense of course um
and i know they're closer with my dad
than i
will ever be
um
so that adds another element of
difficulty
of course
um
i don't know my mom's just had pretty
major surgery she seems pretty feeble
so maybe just a little
an extra nudge when she's on the
crutches down the stairs
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my did they that's funny
um
i don't know bro it's one of this it's
pretty much an impossible question
actually of course it is it's pretty
much an impossible question um i don't
think i can answer it i mean obviously
you're cut throat enough to answer it
but that's fine don't be a [ __ ] yeah
you're you're you're you're heartless
you have to be a terrible question but i
don't think i can do it you have to
answer bro um
mom dad brother
a lot of me is saying brother
really well no this is the thing
a lot of me are saying brother because
you i'm just like how could i ever
possibly kill my mom my dad because i
think it's more of a if i say my brother
it means i don't have to choose between
my mum and my dad which either of them
will get offended with you know what i
mean but the fact of the matter is i'm
close with my brother than i am with
either of them yeah probably both of
them put together than my brother
so i would never do that i would never
pick my brother but then again i can't
pick mom or dad so i don't know what i
don't know what you want me to say bro
it's what i'm trying to get to i'm going
to keep going around in circles until we
move on
that's what i'm going to i just i now
look like the [ __ ] basically nah pham
you did what you had to do man i
understand
but that's the thing what i'm saying is
is if my dad didn't have another family
i would have said my dad as well
for the exact same reasons that you did
purely because i'm closer with my my my
brother than i am or my dad fair enough
that makes sense
but yeah it's good that you factored in
the fact that obviously he's got another
family involved so yeah
um that's not selfish of you i'll kill
myself
it's not an option brother
that's not an option i don't think i
could ever commit suicide
i don't think i could um
but then again obviously i've not been
in a situation where i feel like i need
to take my own life i was gonna say what
possible situation could i ever be in
that i even contemplate it but yeah it's
um
it's a lot you know because
it's obviously easier for me to say
purely because i've never been in such
dire circumstances but
no matter what feeling you're feeling
it is going to be temporary you know
that feeling is temporary so i don't
i don't see why and it's obviously
ignorant for me to say like i said
purely because i've never been in this
situation
but i don't see how you can act on
temporary feelings like don't make rash
decisions of temporary feelings because
people obviously commit suicide yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're feeling
something you know and i'm not negating
the fact that they're feeling what they
feel and they feel like they need to
take their own life i understand that
people do that
um but i just don't see myself doing
that yeah you know i think i i'm sure
i've said this one here before but there
was an analogy that i heard before
about
what it feels like to be suicidal and
the best analogy
like i basically was a like a
a psychologist that was trying to
explain to someone i was listening to on
a pod one time as a psychologist trying
to explain to someone exactly what you
said in terms of how could you possibly
act so rashly on feelings and stuff like
that is that the closest comparison is
being stuck in a
sauna mm-hmm being stuck in a sauna so
you know when you're in a sauna
and you you pretty much firm the heat as
much as you can and you want to get out
and then you're like all right cool i'm
done and you get out it's like he said
being suicidal is like being in a sauna
to the point where you're like okay i
can't handle it anymore and there's no
door to get out
there's no way out of the sauna you have
to stay in the sauna and you're banging
on the window bro banging on the walls
cannot get out of the sauna and you're
getting hotter and hotter and hotter and
you physically cannot get out of this
sauna no matter what you do and the only
way to get out is to [ __ ] cop top
yourself [ __ ] i've never thought about
an aspect i've never heard that analogy
before bro
as soon as you said sauna i was like oh
cause i don't
a lot of heat makes me uncomfortable
period as it is so i don't like sleeping
in heat i don't like being too hot it
just makes i sweat yeah bro it's just
not me being suicidal is living in that
bro you're living it oh man it's tough
man
people that have um like psychological
traumas and things like that and wanting
to be not wanted to be suicidal but
being a position being in a position
where they are suicidal it's like [ __ ] i
i wish i could take that away from them
that's tough man did i ever tell you
about the the lady that um
commit suicide in the floor below me
no you never oh no you never
in your old job
or in my yard
that's how i know you've not told me
when is the floor below me i thought you
meant in your old in your old workplace
nah in my yard no brother
let me sit up no brother bro i can't it
was a couple years ago now i don't
remember all the details
basically there was a mom and two kids
that were were living in the flat below
us
um
mom and two kids living in the flat
below us and um
the mum it used to be the her man
there's the kid's dad that lit there as
well okay she i think she had recently
kicked him out or whatever
okay and they just have domestics she
recently kicked him out he'd moved out
and i can't remember if it was weeks or
months later or whatever
basically
all that happened was is that
we not i say we but
everyone
i say
i say i could hear it but
same time
you just don't notice it so basically
the kids were for like three days the
kids were just crying fam
two or three days
with these kids roughly at the time yeah
remember oh bro like maybe
taking a stab they'll both under
but they're probably like five and three
geez how long ago was this by the way
two three years ago okay i would say two
years ago okay
but um i remember she was a mixed race
woman
and basically the kids were just barling
in there
but
it obviously wasn't constant
so you can't hear the kids crying
constantly and kids [ __ ] cry bro
young kids just cry
so
for me it's one of them ones where like
i would never even you could ask me oh
like like for example if a police
officer was asking me like did you not
hear the kids crying
i would have said no
okay but then i guess if i read because
i wouldn't be able to pinpoint a
specific time where i'm thinking
the kids are crying yeah because it's
such a basic
underlying thing that you would never
notice in a block of flats yeah where
there's bear kids that lived there yeah
you would never notice that but
basically the guy
one of the guys who lives downstairs as
well
was obviously hearing it here in this
neighbor yeah downstairs neighbor was
hearing it hearing it yeah yeah and
after like a day it was i can't remember
if it was it was between one and three
days this is how expected i can't
remember bare details but it was
definitely overnight i know that yeah
it's a couple of days
to the point where my mom was just like
these kids are crying fam yeah like i've
been work i've come home from work i'm
trying to go to bed these youths are
just crying for her so after a couple
days
he kept hearing it so he's obviously not
just to make sure everything's all right
yeah because he obviously just noticed
his kids these kids are crying far more
than usual he hasn't seen any of them
either
so he just knocked no one was answering
the door knocked no one's answering the
door
um and he could hear him crying in there
and i think
i think they called the police
i'm pretty sure they called the police
and just said basically the youth have
been crying in there for days i've been
banging the doorknobs answering the door
um
so call the police please broke in i
should hung myself
and the youths were just in there
with the mom hanging from
dark is that
oh my good god babies were just in there
the mom's just dead fam
oh my good god
the um
thing was at night it was at night as
well
that um they broke in and found her and
stuff
the dad come
i've never seen a human being go as
ballistic as what my man was going
because they wouldn't let him in to get
the use either
obviously they were trying to manage the
whole thing
they wouldn't let him anywhere near the
yard yeah because because
because it's all coming back now because
yeah i'm getting more details flashbacks
i'm getting more details yeah because
her family her mom or something was
taking custody of the kids okay and i
think she'd told
the police or something that she reckons
he's to blame
or he might have done something or he
might have something to do with it
yeah yeah i think that's what the mum
said something like that or she would
never do this she would never do this it
must have been him or something like
that so my man's heard
your youths have been in this yard for
two days yeah
with a dead body yeah he's combust true
give me my utes now yeah and i police
are like you're not seeing your utes
kind of thing you've never seen a grown
man go crazy like that
bro you've never seen a grown man go
crazy like that
he went super saiyan 3 bro no way he
lost his [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh i can imagine oh
i can imagine bro [ __ ]
i would knock jaws off i could imagine
brother i would knock jaws off give me
my utes
give me my use now
you're telling me my two yous have been
up in there with a corpse for two three
days
and i can't come near them
they're
traumatized they need me
come out the way now and there's gonna
be more than one corpse up in here
there's gonna be bodies it's gonna be
there's gonna be four days
oh bro
jesus christ crazy
crazy
and um i'm not even sure if you've got
the kids in the end
i can't remember before he was the name
of the team this brother bro i don't
know two years ago roughly yeah about
two years ago wow
wild my g wow
the thing is like
when it comes to stuff like um suicide
and that um obviously i'm not an expert
obviously i
i don't know anyone that's committed
suicide and things like that
but
that scenario he gave me
i feel like more time it's when
people are in
bad relationships and they're like kids
involved and like things like that where
people try and
get find a way out but that's the only
way out you know and it's like
[ __ ] like you said the trap trapped in a
sauna thing like she probably thought
she was trapped in a sword and she can
never be free 100 g i mean
she could at least unlock the [ __ ]
door
bro five and three obviously you said
stabbing the dog you don't know how old
they were they were young i know they
were yeah of course of course but
the older one has cognitive
understanding of what's going on
you know she knows that she knows life
and death she knows what death means
surely she knows like something's wrong
mum's not moving the three-year-old
maybe not
but a five-year-old
they must have been starving as well big
man had it eaten the utes must have been
starving
broke my heart when i heard i killed him
bro it's breaking my heart hearing it i
felt so guilty
why because i'm in the i'm oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay i was thinking about
i'm just walking up and says with
leisure
just hearing youths cry i don't think i
don't remember hearing anyone cry
but i'm always hearing you crying
i'm always hearing you squaring my
building yeah yeah yeah i wouldn't think
twice about it yeah same same way
like
same way i always think this as well
like i could be in bed and like i
flipping an alarm goes off down the road
yeah and the first thing i do is kiss my
teeth and roll over fam yeah there could
be someone getting murdered over there
and police could be knocking my door
like i did not hear that i'm like yeah i
[ __ ] heard the alarm bro i was vexed
like it was 5 00 a.m
it was five p.m just shut that stupid
alarm off i start working a couple hours
what do you mean yeah livid but like it
just i don't know you get desensitized
to certain things yeah of course of
course of course and then yeah obviously
it was it was only ever going to be my
my don that lived next to them
took him a couple days to think like
he's used to being piling far more than
that's normal
um but that's the thing as well and i
it's i'm just glad there's people out
there sometimes i'm just glad there's
people out there that aren't like
me yeah that take go the extra mile
initiative bro yeah i know what you mean
because i feel like it would have been
longer for me yeah it would they would
have had to been seriously disrupting my
sleep for me to do something about it i
mean if they were asleep at like
um if they're just sleeping in their
normal sleep because they're young
they're going to need a lot of sleep
regardless of what's going on the only
way i feel like i would have reacted is
two options either one if it was like
three four five days in a row where i'm
like okay i'm noticing this now this is
getting ridiculous or if that i can hear
them balling at like four in the morning
until god knows when
and there's no i'm not hearing any adult
yeah yeah that's when i'm thinking oh
that would have been night one yeah
night one if i'm hearing a ball from
from three till six and i'm not hearing
any adults that's what i'm going
straight over there but yeah
i but if it's not in the middle of the
night my gee i promise you if especially
if i'm going work in the day yeah
i would be oblivious
oblivious bro and even if i found it
annoying if i'm coming home at night and
i'm making dinner i can hear him crying
i might just shut the [ __ ] kids up
man yeah and then just get on my day
i know and it even sometimes it annoys
me because i even think like
i know the first time if it was in if
it's if it's in respectable hours
the first time wouldn't be the time i
would take action of course not the
first time i think is everything all
right bro cause these are barling yeah i
still wouldn't do anything yeah knowing
me because you think it's just a one-off
kind of thing yeah i'll be thinking is
everything all right because the these
are one shot up by i'm not going to get
involved yeah i'm not going to get in my
place especially if i know there's been
a history of obviously her beef and her
man kicking her man out all these things
i'm especially not i'm thinking i'm
going to stay out of it yeah i'm just
going to stay out of here it would have
to be like two more days of it where
it's a point where i'm thinking what's
going on this is silly now yeah
and i'm so happy it wasn't me down there
bro because if i found out that i had
ignored red flags
to only find out that when push push
push came to shaft that my god have been
dead in there for days
and the babies have just been in there
seeing that the whole time for days
i wouldn't know what to do with myself
i would break i would never forgive
myself
never i'm thinking about if i forgive
myself i'm that person i know i could i
don't think i'd forgive myself either
[ __ ] man
that's so deep bro it's dark in it it's
podcast has taken a very dark turn very
dark
this is taking a very dark life man like
people go through [ __ ] that no one knows
until you know you're not
that's um
it is a shame like uh
i hate that
some people have to go through that and
i hate that that that's
that the only out that they think is not
necessarily acceptable but the only way
they can feel free again is if they top
themselves
i hate that man
i hate that but that's the only out they
see
that's crazy to me it's cr it's barbaric
to me
you know that's pop barry
is
on
comprehensible
like you can't
even begin to understand it
it's it's a different language
because people don't just have suicidal
thoughts people have suicidal thoughts
because of other people
or because of other situations like it's
nothing to it's not necessarily anything
to do with them it's like something's
happening in life that's affected them
you know yeah bro that's a ping
ping that's the thing with like um you
know people like in abusive
relationships and stuff like that yeah
that's the big one
that's the big one when you're an
abusive relationship and you don't think
there's any way out of it yeah because
they manipulate and control your life
bro imagine i can imagine they control
where you go they control when you go
they control who you speak to especially
if you have kids because you always have
to come back bro
and there's no other option you try to
leave they manage to get you back
they're in control of your finances
they're in control of everything bro and
they keep everyone under your farm
under their farm they make they make you
out to be a crazy person
and then they're just abusing you
emotionally bro constantly constantly
constantly there's no way out and you've
got no money bro you've got no money so
even if you do leave
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do where are you gonna go
what are you gonna do so you're stuck
there that's when people top themselves
bro people that
take advantage and manipulate and
put other people in that scenario need
to go straight to hellfire car that is
not on brother
that's not on
that's just not on it's just not
what right what mental state are you in
to do that to somebody big man i don't
know how dare you feel like you've got
the right to own someone's life like
that
bro that's how people feel though but
when you're in relationship people
some people think that's mine
that's mine
that some people do i own that so that's
my property
family that is um
yeah this this went a little bit dark
still
it did because obviously it's coming off
the back of a real scenario and she's
like [ __ ] man those kids
and you said this was like two years ago
now so a little bit older now they
understand what's happened they
understand that the mother's gone like
the dad is god knows you know it's
that's their lives ruined brother big
man ruined and the thing to top it is
imagine this right
imagine you
so it's a two-bedroom flat yeah imagine
you you live in a two-bedroom flat yeah
imagine there was a stranger's
corpse in your flat for two days and you
can't get out of the flat you as a 30
year old man what that will do to you
if there's a corpse in the living room
hanging from the ceiling
and you're stuck with it for two days
and you cannot get out you as a
grown-ass man i would lose my marble
you'd lose your marbles now imagine
being a five-year-old kid and that
corpse is your mum
no brother
what are we doing bro
how can that possibly
happen
wow man
that's not okay
that's just not okay man
that's um
i don't know how it's how wow i can't
get my wizard i don't know how i'd react
but i know
for a fact that i wouldn't be able to
take it like if i was like you said that
scenario if i'm a 30 year old man as i
am now random body just hanging from my
ceiling
and i'm trapped there for two days
brother can't get out
can't get out you have to live your life
moving around the body you then have to
sleep bro you have to sleep
at some point you have to sleep
just knowing there's a corpse in there
you have to eat you have to wash your
skin you have to just live your life you
as a grown-ass man
not being imagined being a five-year-old
bro you can't wash yourself you can't
clean yourself you can't cook you can't
cook order anything you can't feed
yourself you can't do anything you can't
call anyone you can't talk to anyone all
you can do is scream at the top of your
lungs and you've been doing that for two
[ __ ] days and no one's calm
absolutely petrified
and you can just hear people living
their lives all around you no one's
hearing you cry bro
do you imagine what that could do what
that must do to you for the rest of your
life
how many like psychological issues you
must develop from that those two days
alone
crying at the top of your lungs for two
days straight and no one came
wow
your dad is nowhere to be seen wow
the only person that's been looking
after you is hanging from the ceiling
dead
you are locked in this yard
screaming you can hear the next-door
neighbor walking past you every day here
in ukraine just getting on with his day
cars coming back and forth hoping
someone's going to bust through that
door any second
bro you've got your little brother or
sister screaming don't know what's going
on you have to look after them as well
yeah and they look after them as well
yeah
yeah
wow
oh dear me so i'm just very very very
very this sounds so so selfish but for
my own mental state i'm just so happy
that i know for a fact during that time
i never had that
thought of god those kids are crying a
lot that i'm so happy that i know for a
fact that never crossed my mind that no
i was so oblivious and it makes me feel
bad still
but i don't even i might i might not
have even heard them cry at all
and
selfishly that makes me feel better
within myself because same thing if i if
i could have remembered at that time
that there was a point within those
couple of days
that i'd thought
[ __ ] those kids are yeah
even for a millisecond and then i found
out that that's what had happened
oh fear till
oh bro
i don't know what i'd do how did you
find out
were you at home when the police came
all i heard was why i'm done screaming
outside fam oh the dads that's how i
found out the dad when the dad was
screaming outside okay i woke up in the
middle like i seen all the blue flashes
i look outside mama's going nuts
and i had no idea what was going on i
thought it was some domestic thing yeah
i thought he was getting arrested or
something
he was going nuts
and then i found out the next day what
happened
jeez man
that's um that's dark
yep um
anyway
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
guys
um
yeah it's good stuff over there
[Laughter]
it's good wholesome content over there
really light-hearted conversations yeah
man funny [ __ ] funny [ __ ] um
so anyway um
on our next episode we're going to be
reading out tick-tock comments we are so
join us over on patreon um and we're
going to see the abuse that we get over
there
love you guys yeah man
deuces we'll see you soon peace
[Music]